so what you may have heard about the
restaurant
a few weeks after we opened our western
themed restaurant there was an
altercation where a man was brutally
beaten outside of the restaurant show up
in the morning there's
there's crime scene tape everywhere
there's police officers i was talking
with some of the officers that i knew
asking what had happened
and there was a man who was beaten
pretty badly and he ended up losing his
life and so that immediately prompted
the question of me how am i going to
take care of everyone how am i going to
protect the people that are around me
so i went across the street and talked
to a local um gun dealer a gun salesman
and uh and i asked him about colorado's
carry laws he said well you can carry
openly without a permit
so that's what i did i began to open
carry soon after that my waitresses
began to open carry and the next thing
you know shooter's grill was being
called the safest restaurant in america
so i actually didn't know that part of
your story but it's a pretty perfect
through line to you own a restaurant
yeah yeah yeah so you were doing
something right back in high school at
mcdonald's yes i'm a very spontaneous
person by nature sometimes i see it as
my greatest downfall but sometimes it
works out pretty well and i ended up
leaving mcdonald's and i went to the oil
and gas industry for a while i was
filing some papers at a local company
and then decided to go out in the field
and do work and i was a pipeline
technician
so locating pipeline doing cathodic
protection
without an engineering degree
it's possible to do work without a
four-year
college degree and and so i was
locating pipelines i was gpsing the
pipelines making maps of them doing
cathodic protection which um is
we install anodes
to protect the pipe from corroding and
and so it's just this fascinating part
of my job that i loved and got to drive
all around the valley and hike up and
down mountains locating these pipes and
making sure they were protected
and then the oil and gas industry
started to be heavily regulated
and colorado
saw the industry pulling out
so a lot of us our days were numbered i
ended up leaving and decided to be a
stay-at-home mom i had three boys then
and
said you know i'm gonna just be with my
boys for a while
and unfortunately a little bit later um
it got worse and so my husband ended up
running out of contracts and he wasn't
working in the industry anymore and we
said we needed a plan b uh there was a
local restaurant that shut down
and uh it was one of our favorites it
was called the cowboy cafe
c-a-l-f-a yes
yes
and they closed down and they had a four
rent sign in the window and we drove by
one day and said
maybe
maybe we could do this and so we went in
it was a great deal to lease the place
the equipment was there and we decided
whenever he went back to work to start
investing those um his paycheck into the
restaurant and and opening it up very
spontaneous never owned a restaurant
before
but i wanted a way to give back to my
community a lot of our friends were
unemployed and they needed opportunity
again and that opportunity wasn't there
in the oil and gas industry like it had
been and so we opened up we we hired our
waitresses our our kitchen staff and we
were just a western themed restaurant
wanting to give excellent service to our
community
and it was it was a pretty great place
when we first opened i didn't have a lot
of money i didn't have any money for
advertising so we went door-to-door on
the first day to each business and said
hey come in and have a free meal on us
and that was cheaper than any
advertising i could have done and it
worked people liked it and they were
coming back
so what you may have heard about the
restaurant
a few weeks after we opened our western
themed restaurant there was an
altercation where a man was brutally
beaten outside of the restaurant show up
in the morning there's
there's crime scene tape everywhere
there's police officers i was talking
with some of the officers that i knew
asking what had happened and there was a
man who was beaten pretty badly and he
ended up losing his life and so that
immediately prompted the question of me
how am i going to take care of everyone
how am i going to protect the people
that are around me
so i went across the street and talked
to a local um gun dealer a gun salesman
and uh and i asked him about colorado's
carry laws he said well you can carry
openly without a permit
so that's what i did i began to open
carry soon after that my waitresses
began to open carry and the next thing
you know shooter's grill was being
called the safest restaurant in america
shooter's grill so there there is the
name yeah and there have been no
shootings no shooters grill people are
not murdering each other or anything
like that you know it's interesting
because you mentioned at the top that
your story the democrats should sort of
love your story but in a way i get why
they hate your story you came from
nothing you worked hard you did a bunch
of stuff you kept growing you care about
family right
that's a problem yeah they can't have
the success story right
they they are okay with you turning a
blind eye to their failures you know if
the um if the man in the white house has
a son who's lost three laptops and is uh
addicted to smoking parmesan cheese you
know we can turn a blind eye to that um
if a cnn uh
analysis you know gets caught doing some
very very horrendous inappropriate
things on a zoom meeting then you know
that's okay as long as he comes on and
says i'm sorry um but no that that real
life
when things get tough you get tougher
and um and you make success out of
failures you learn from your mistakes
and you continue you don't let um that
hold you back or keep you down and and
you offer to other people a way to have
success in their lives that is what they
hate so when did you decide okay i've
got these ideas my life's in order now
restaurant's working got the family let
me get into politics
so um let me throw that all away right
well you know being in the restaurant i
mean a lot of people come in there
complaining about the issues of the day
um i think you and i um could probably
relate with um being involved in
republican uh politics because we're
both kind of new to that
i voted republican but i i wasn't paying
attention to who i was voting for why i
was voting for them um and what happened
in between those elections and so i'm
actually fairly new to that process i
just know as a business owner
they were affecting my business they
were affecting my family um they were
affecting the paychecks that we were
able to bring home i was electing
people who i thought had my same views
but then they would get to washington dc
or to the state capitol over regulate
over tax overspend and destroy
everything that we're trying to build at
home and so we talk about that kind of
stuff in the restaurant and
i really believe that
a lot of our problems in america is
because we had an entire generation at
least say you're not allowed to talk
about religion or politics and now we
have an entire generation that is
ignorant about the things of god
and government and you're not allowed to
have politics religion yes basically yes
exactly that that is their god
government is their god and that's why
they believe that government can come in
and rule you and you need to submit and
they can take rights away from you
because they are the grantor
of those rights speaking my language yes
yes and so um in my restaurant you're
free to talk about those things even if
you disagree with me
freedom of speech is so under attack
right now and if we lose that we lose
everything
hate speech is free speech
speech that you disagree with is free
speech and this is something that we
have to protect so this isn't just a
second amendment issue or a tenth
amendment issue
this is everything our our livelihoods
and everything moving forward we know
what big tech is doing to censor um uh
freedom of speech and really i it's the
first time in history that
big tech somewhat an entity this big
is more of a threat than big government
because this is someone playing the role
of government in your life and taking
things from you it's it's bizarre
but
i didn't want to just sit and complain
about what was going on i wanted to be a
part of the solution
and i didn't know what that meant um but
suddenly uh there was this um
suave pretty boy from texas um who got
up on a pr presidential debate stage
and he slipped up
beto o'rourke told the whole world what
democrats planned to do with your second
amendment he said hell yes we're going
to take your ar-15s and your ak-47s
so i got pretty upset and i drove to his
presidential rally my husband said what
are you doing well you that's three
hours away like we don't have the fuel
the the extra gas money to do that and i
said no i'm going to talk to this guy he
said you just think they're going to let
you talk to him it's like i don't know
i'm but i'm going very spontaneous so i
drove three hours to his presidential
rally with my glock on my hip and uh i
looked him in the eye and told him hell
no you're not and i i
you know i was just so frustrated and
millions of americans were just as
frustrated as me and they were reaching
out to me saying thank you this is
exactly what we felt and i said who is
speaking up for them
and if if me just a mom of four boys
from rifle colorado a restaurant owner
can say something so impactful that the
nation listens
what else could i do to help bring
awareness to what's happening and hold
these people accountable and try to
try to make a such a bad situation right
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell